this is a production of Cornell
University
oh thank you for being here I'll get
started so how many of you have heard of
this proverb we are what we eat or you
are what you eat a lot of you right okay
how many of you have heard of this one
yeah no one well it doesn't exist I
actually made it up but hopefully by the
end of this talk I'll convince you that
it's not actually far-fetched so in a
striking majority of the developing
world food systems including those set
out by the Green Revolution have failed
to provide the necessary the necessary
forms and quantity of essential
nutrients needed for optimal human
health so the Green Revolution was
really successful in addressing the
problems of food insecurity or hunger
but sort of overlooked the the sort of
it's as important a problem of nutrition
security or malnutrition so scientists
have primarily focused on less less
sustainable methods and interventions
such as fortification and
supplementation whereas intervention
surrounding the soil which forms the
foundation of life has been
disproportionately lacking so soil
serves as the primary source of minerals
to humans it is both direct and indirect
source via the food chain and it's also
a direct source through soil ingestion
inhalation or dermal absorption but the
latter happens in such my new quantities
and it's also for the case of soil
ingestion is is socially awkward water
is also another source of minerals but
it generally is low it supplies around
less than 5% of the required total daily
intake with the exception of calcium and
magnesium which can provide up to 20%
[Music]
okay
so as such humans and livestock that
monotonous ly consumed locally derived
diets subsisting on cereals grown on
nutrient depleted soils will often
exhibit the same or a related nutrient
deficiency and this has been well
established for example India produces
enough food to feed its entire
population yet it has the highest
prevalence of malnutrition in the world
and this is can be attributed to two
reasons it's partly attributed to the
narrow focus on calorie dense crops that
the Green Revolution really championed
and knew of the nutritionally
invigorating ones and also because of
the major depletion of the soils
nutrient reservoir as a result of the
continuous cultivation of the same
technology but we must not forget that a
healthy life is not possible without
healthy soils as was promoted in the
International Year of soils so what is
soil health soil health is a concept
it's that looks at soil holistically
drawing away from the more traditional
outlook on soils that are purely
chemically driven and emphasizes the
less appreciated biological and physical
attributes of a soil in other words it's
the intersection of the soils physical
biological and chemical states that are
anthropogenically influenced so what we
want to know is whether we can relate
soil health to human health in other
words our soil health constraints
reflected on human nutritional status so
not much work has been done in this
discipline discipline especially in
recent years and almost never on a
household level and it's partly because
of the complex relationships that exist
between soil and human health which are
difficult to extricate and and also
because of the presence of many
confounding factors some of the research
that has been done includes one that was
conducted in the Kishan disease belt of
China Kashan disease as a is a selenium
deficiency disorder and the study basic
basically looked at the Saleen
distribution of in the soil the grain
and the humans and they found that it
significantly decreased the
concentration significantly decreased
with increasing incidents of Keshawn
disease another study conducted in to
high prevalence of esophageal cancers in
South Africa and Iran and they found
that the low levels of molybdenum and
zinc in the soils were significantly
associated with the prevalence of this
cancer a third one also conducted in two
agricultural regions of China known for
their centenarian and nonagenarian
residents and have found a connection
between the soils the water and the
staples of those regions with this human
health attribute and the last example is
a study conducted in mud and tribal
districts of Madhya Pradesh India and
they found a strong entered
interdependence of zinc content
unlike soil grain and serum blood
samples in this region and this is well
established as you can see in this so in
this map the areas with high zinc
deficiency are co-located with the areas
with high human zinc deficiency so these
all these all these studies are although
extremely informative their shortfalls
lie in the fact that they only studied
one mineral nutrient at a time and
they've been studied in isolation the
other
shortfall is that they only focus on the
soil chemical properties and so did we
didn't really look at the biological and
the physical states
so that's why I decided to study the
link between soil health as a whole were
and rice and human health and I did that
in Darkon India
Jharkhand is a state located in the
northeast part of India its population
is thirty thirty percent of its
population is tribal against the
national level of eight percent they are
they are resource poor infrastructurally
isolated subsistence rice farmers eighty
percent of the cropland is covered in
intensively mono crop trained fed rice
in India rice contributes to
approximately half the daily calorie
caloric intake and it's a presume to be
higher in charka it also has it has a
devastating health crisis it has and
it's considered one of the highest
health burden states of India it has the
highest prevalence of underweight
children 45% child mortality due to
severe malnutrition gender based food
consumption disparity where women often
receive less nutrients both in quantity
and quality because they're often eating
the leftovers of their husbands and
their children 35 percent of rural women
have below normal BMI up to 85 percent
of women are anemic and the maternal
mortality ratio is 312 that's why the
goal of the study is to identify the
characteristics and interrelations of
soil plant and human nutritional health
and Jerkins rice systems to better
address the issues of adult female
malnutrition so I'll be covering two
parts the first is a quick overview of
some of the minerals present in the soil
rice and humans and the second is the
assessment of the of the inter-linkages
between these three mediums so within
the
of this assessment minerals were
categorized into four categories so we
have the essential mineral
micronutrients the essential mineral
macronutrients the potentially
beneficial trace elements and the toxic
elements so while I'll be reporting each
minerals essential ality to plants to
humans and their functions briefly I'll
also be reporting some thresholds or
baseline values that allow us to know
what the optimal concentration our
concentrations are in each medium for
soil they will be reported in terms of
may leak 3 in parts per million for rice
they will be reported in terms of
maximum permissible level whenever the
the information is available otherwise
that recommended dietary allowance and
that's in milligrams per day and the
maximum tolerable intake which is also
reported in milligrams per day and then
for human hair and I'll explain why
human hairs is important in such studies
they'll be reported in terms of
reference ranges and they're either in
the 5th to 95th percentile or the 10th
to 90th percentiles
and these just represent the normal
range so all that all the new all the
minerals are reported in in this table
and the next three tables behind these
these four tables went a major probing
of the literature that lasted for months
and resulted in seventy page literature
review but so I'll be reporting so I'll
be reporting just the first two but I
encourage you to really look at really
look at these values and if you disagree
with them please do let me know at the
end of the talk and we can discuss them
so these are these were really the best
I could find from that those four
month-long literature review so boron is
essential to plants and humans it's
knowing boron is essential to plants and
it
expected to be beneficial to humans it
hasn't been really conclusively proven
so and plants it's important for protein
formation amongst others and for humans
it's suspected to be important for for
the metabolism of minerals the soil may
leak 3 deficiency critical level is 0.4
the toxicity critical level is 5 the
there is no RDA because it hasn't been
conclusively proven to be essential and
the NCI is 20 again RDA recommended
dietary allowance MTI is maximum
tolerable intake and then the human hair
reference ranges are 0.26 to 1.87
reported for a study conducted in canada
and 0 to 3 in poland cobalt is essential
to own to humans and hasn't been
conclusively proven to be essential at
least not directly to plants because
they don't
it's the nitrogen fixing bacteria that
that need cobalt and for humans it
actually constitutes the backbone of
vitamin b12 the soil may leak 3
deficiency or tox toxicity critical
level is for the RDA there is no RDA the
maximum permissible level in rice grains
is 0.5 and these are the reference
ranges and so you can you can look at
these I won't be covering them I'll just
say that chromium is essential to humans
copper iron manganese is essential to
both molybdenum is essential molybdenum
nickel is essential to both plants of
humans selenium is only essential to
humans and our intake of selenium really
relies on the inadvertent update of
selenium by plants titanium is
beneficial to plants a vanadium
beneficial to plants and suspected to be
essential to humans and zinc is
essential to both plants and humans now
on the map
nutrients all of them except for sodium
are essential to both plants and humans
and then for the toxic elements aluminum
arsenic barium cadmium lead and
strontium strontium were all assessed
against these sort of baseline values
all right
sample collection in 2015
soil samples were collected from
randomly selected rice fields across
seven districts in India and jocund
India in 2018 rice and hair human hair
samples were collected from the female
to female individuals in the households
that have been cultivating and
subsisting on the rice fields that that
we collected soil samples from
additionally to the fields rice that was
collected we also collected the
government subsidized publicly public
distribution system rice because it
often because it often constitutes the
second most consumed rice in the
household after the one that's grown by
these by these households and so why
hair why why are we assessing hair for
nutrition nutrition status
well hair has many advantages over the
assessment of blood or urine first it's
non-invasive second it's it's it's a
long-term bio indicator so it's able to
reveal a retrospective information about
a human's nutritional status over an
extended period of time
and third it's easy to store and to
transport so soil samples were subjected
to against a set of physical biological
and chemical health indicators the
physical indicators included by
aggregate stability available water
capacity capacity surface and subsurface
compaction the biological indicators
included organic matter acts of carbon
solar respiration and soul protein and
the
indicators include a pH and all of the
elements that we discussed earlier for
the soil the samples were assessed for
available content using malloc 3
extraction for the rice and hair they
were they were analyzed for total and
they were quantified using the icp-oes
in addition to these elements the we
also analyzed phytate so phytate is a is
a it's a natural compound found in many
in many cereal grains it's an anti
nutrient that inhibits the absorption of
iron and zinc so it interferes with the
absorption of iron zinc in the gut and
that was analyzed using a commercially
available kit called magazine magazine
and the procedure basically includes
briefly the extraction of phytate and
then undergoing a series of the
enzymatic dephosphorylation reactions
adding a color reagent and quantifying
at clark color quick quantifying it
spectra with a spectrophotometer these
were sampled in India and if I Tate was
done for the rice okay so in order to
interpret the results soil and or rice
samples were translated into scores of
100 or 0 on the basis of sufficiency or
deficiency toxicity when the thresholds
were available as I pointed out in the
tables otherwise we we basically
computed the percent contribution of the
nutrients in the rice to their our das
the recommended dietary allowance when
applicable and hair as you saw that
there was a huge lack of agreement
amongst the reference ranges and so we
we crudely compared the our samples to
the reference ranges so were they above
below or within at least one reference
ranges that was found in the that was
found in the literature
all right so the results of the soil
health analysis revealed that 95 percent
of our soil sample samples were below
the wet aggregate stability critical
level seven percent were below the
available water capacity critical level
79 percent and 57 percent were below the
surface and subsurface compaction
critical level so a big proportion of
the soil samples were suboptimal as it
relates to soil so a physical health
these results imply that the current
physical state of darken soils is
largely a result of the degradative
influence of the popularly adopted
management practices of puddling for
paddy rice production so which you know
destroys the the structure of the soil
similarly the the results for those soil
biological health analysis so showed
that 93 percent of our soil samples were
below the threshold for organic matter
content and 100 calm all of the soil
samples were below were suboptimal as it
relates to active carbon
protein and respiration and these
results suggest that darken patty soils
are extremely biologically poor which
may be factored by the continuous
monoculture and undiversified rice
cultivation okay so now looking at the
soil the the mineral concentrations in
the soil so we find that 51 percent of
soil samples were deficient in boron
65% were in excess barium 28% we're
deficient in calcium 12% in excess
cobalt nine and three percent efficient
and in excess copper respectively 16
percent in excess iron 86 percent
deficient and potassium thirty and forty
nine percent deficient and in excess
manganese seven percent in excess sodium
two percent in excess nickel 95%
deficient and phosphorus five percent in
excess lead 37 percent deficient in
sulfur and 86 percent deficient in zinc
and these results shows that suggests
that darken soils are constrained by
limitations in the content of essential
elements and my toxic bye bye xx toxins
so we also see that darkened soils are
constrained also by the chemical state
so moving on to rice we can make three
we can we can make three observations
the first one is that field and PDS
samples contributed to the micro in
micro nutrient RDA
on average between one and three percent
for calcium one 185 and 274 for chromium
with no potential toxicity 77 and 78
percent for copper between 11 and 19
percent for iron 19 and 17 percent for
potassium 42 and 29 percent for
magnesium 201 and 78 percent for
manganese with 2 percent of field rice
samples exceeding the MTI 260 and 280
four percent for molybdenum with no
samples exceeding the MTI point 46 and
point 32 for sodium 68 and 62% for
phosphorus and between 13 and 25 percent
for zinc and when we considered the rice
zinc concentration critical levels more
than ninety percent of samples were
considered deficient and finally about
80 percent exceeded the lead critical
level
okay the second observation we can make
is that filled rice samples were
significantly higher than pds rice
samples in calcium potassium magnesium
manganese and zinc all of which are
essential macro and micronutrients so
again the field dry samples had higher
significantly higher micronutrient and
macronutrient content than the
government subsidized public
distribution system rice the third
observation we can make know relates to
the phytate to mineral molar ratio which
was computed to predict the inhibitory
effect of the anti-nutrient phytate on
the on the bioavailability of zinc and
iron and it showed us that almost all of
our rice samples were sub optimal sub
optimal by exceeding the thresholds so
that means there's more fight by
take-two iron concentrations so these
results suggest that rice consumed by
the women of Darkon are by and large
fulfilling the micronutrient RDA to some
acceptable degree with the large
exception of critical micronutrients
iron and zinc those are those are big
ones and this may be due to the phytate
- iron and zinc ratios to a lesser
degree is the rice fulfilling the
macronutrient RDA and hair not much can
be said using our crude method we found
that the elements that were within at
least one of the reference ranges were
calcium cobalt chromium copper nickel
sulfur titanium vanadium and zinc the
elements that were above at least one of
the reference ranges were aluminum
barium cadmium lead strontium potassium
iron manganese magnesium manganese and
and sodium and phosphorus was the only
one below it is important to keep in
mind however that this categorization
may or may not be indicated existing
constraints due to the multitude and
often contradict in reference ranges as
we saw earlier and that is why human
hair analysis has yet to become widely
adopted because every studies is sort of
expected
to define its own healthy population and
to be used as a baseline in their in
their studies so the question is do the
constraints in the soil translate to
constraints in the rice and the hair
well let's see some of these results
suggest that the content of some
elements in rice and subsequently hair
contribution to human nutrition may be
dependent on their respective content in
the soil like a good example is chromium
and molybdenum but not all soup a good
example of it not corresponding well is
iron so the excess iron in the soil may
not be associated with similar trends in
the rice as evidenced by its low
contribution to the RDA relatively low
and this could largely be due to the
bioavailability dilemma but it is
parallel to human hair levels
similarly 95% of jar consoles are
phosphorous deficient yet the rice that
grows on the soil to contribute to 68
percent of the RDA but are all but also
paralleled with with with hair finally
five percent of samples exhibited excess
lead while 80 percent of the rice grown
on these on these soils have excess lead
so why is that so so in any case we
should really take these results with a
grain of salt because because of this
phenomenon you know are the critical
levels or reference reagents even
reliable are they valid are they
compatible in the case of lead is there
another source of content contamination
how about the other sources of mineral
and in the diet I mean surely they don't
just eat rice
how about mineral available
bioavailability so that's why we the why
further analyses are warranted to verify
these connections using be used in our
preliminary step we use Pearson's
correlations to verify this so I don't
expect you to I don't expect you to to
be able to read I mean I'm gonna walk
you through these results but if you if
you would like to follow along soil is
in the x-axis hair isn't the positive Y
and rice is in the negative Y so we've
the results suggests that soil physical
and biological health indicators are
significantly correlated to rice and
hair mineral content the leaf there are
associated benefits of higher physical
soil health to humans via increased
availability of essential nutrients and
decreased availability of potentially
toxic elements we also found that
organic matter is beneficial not only in
its supply of nutrients to plants but
also in its association with suppression
of potential plant and human toxicity
we also found associated benefits of
higher soil biological health and
specifically soil protein content on the
of lethal toxins such as lead in rice in
general these results suggest that soil
physical and biological health
indicators are quite correlated with
rice and human health nutritional status
all right so here we have and again if
you this is for those who want we would
like to follow along
we have soil in the x-axis hair in the Y
and rice in the D the the results
suggest that an increase in toxic
elements in soil is associated with an
increase in other toxic elements in rice
and we found that for soil aluminum
arsenic and cadmium with rice barium
possible antigone antagonistic effects
between soil and rice toxins and that
was the case for soil cadmium arsenic
aluminum as they were as they relate to
rice LED higher micronutrient content
and soil is associated with decreasing
toxin concentrations in rice and we saw
this with soil boron iron potassium and
molybdenum and selenium with rice lead
toxicity and rice associated with the
same and different toxins and hair but
in general the soil to hair trend was
unclear given the indirect relationship
via nutrition the directly link between
hair minerals and soil physical and
biological health indicators or to a
certain degree more apparent than with
soil minerals so in conclusion human
health is a main pillar and sustainable
agriculture and should be at the
forefront of the agricultural systems
agenda it is known that the resources
that shape our environment play an
immense role in determining our health
as individuals and communities
specifically the soil which forms the
foundation of life Jerkins soils are
characterized by poor health in all
aspects the soil status was to a certain
degree reflected nutritionally on rice
and humans and further
research is warranted in this discipline
so the next step so what I presented
where it was more of the preliminary
statistical analysis the next steps will
include some multivariate analysis and
perhaps the path analysis and lasso
regression also in an in vitro iron
bioavailability assessment studying how
the soil of how the socio demographic
and lifestyle effects the soil
rice and human health and conducting
some spatial analyses in other words our
soil toxicity and human toxicity
co-located and is that a result of
proximity to industrial facilities I'd
like to acknowledge the NSF and the Tata
Cornell Institute being my two funders
and I'm happy to take any questions
[Applause]
yeah we can start to just the literature
to see what are some of the thresholds
that that uh you know the the general
consensus was on for each element they
were between four point five and five
point five so pretty acidic yes you have
the two sources of right through the
department's of where you stand and so
did you look at the proportionality of
those and yeah no not not for this not
for this step we we don't know the
proportions we did part as part of a
survey we did ask them what in what
quantities or how how often do they eat
or how many how much time how many times
do they eat rice per day but we didn't
really differentiate would which so they
all they we did ask which was the
dominant and some of them said both all
of them said the dominant source is the
the is from what they grow and then if
they run out then that's when they
revert to the PDS rice
the homegrown rice process kind of
similarly or very differently from the
commercial yeah so what they do is they
take their rice and they go to the
village mill and they they mill it
I assume that the government also I
don't I don't I don't assume to be to
have any there I don't think they would
be different so but I don't have such
information indicated he writes as part
of the distribution system is a lower
quality right so that may be because
it's being grown in other parts of the
country probably further west perhaps
those soils are in worse shape
correct correct and and and you know
when the the PDS rice is really just
about having enough stocks you know it's
just trying to maximize yields and so
really so if any type of fertilization
that would go into the rice that that's
yeah that's acquired by the PDS system
where were the PDS is really those that
have been fertilized to maximize yield
and not really micronutrient content you
indicated that the critical level so it
was my understanding that the soil
health indicators have not been
established so far so we're using the us
criterion correct
so typically so what I so what I did for
my Master's is I created my own scoring
so I adapted the framework to and
created my own and that's because I was
able to I had a large enough sample so I
had two hundred my sample size was 255
in this case I can't yes they were
normally distributed but I can't my
sample size is small too small for me to
just assume that this is this is
everything you know and just base my
create my own scoring functions so
that's a little baby a potential
fracture absolutely absolutely so but
are you analyzing I understand the issue
with the information about what what the
contents in here samples need are you
looking at just trying to looking at
correlations with uptake because you
have quantitative information about the
amount in the hair so I guess I'm asking
like it would be useful information to
just relate that to the to the rice in
the soil correct and that's what we see
even though you can write exactly and
that's what we did Pearson's
correlations and hope so this is just
really the preliminary step and then
we'll take it more to multiple doing
some multivariate analyses water source
yeah I think you know I yeah I think
that another PhD student in the Tata
Cornell I think was looking at water so
yeah that is an important it is
important but it's effective so drinking
water right but irrigation water is it's
it's
rain-fed these are rain-fed systems so
it wouldn't be through the the rice
it wouldn't be through the rice
intermediate so it would be just direct
consumption and water drinking water
like him relation to other biomarkers
kinda like what do we know about here on
vs. yeah so what I do know about urine
and blood is that the the issue that
researchers that use these these
bio-indicators is that they change by
the hour so in the case of blood it's
not really really reliable because it
changes every hour and the same for
urine changes every day so that those
are the main constraints yet most
researchers still use that because they
they have we know what the thresholds is
and hair the limitation is that each
study is sort of defining its own normal
reference range you know and so there is
no there is no agreement and that's why
it's not really widely adopted does that
answer your question yeah I haven't come
across such studies but it's not to say
that they don't exist yeah but it's
something that you raise early
concentration there is one
dance and face them to make a stand then
it was nearly station what fresh seven
o'clock yeah yeah no for sure well when
I collected when I collected these hair
samples I actually I bought a Barbie and
cut off a strand to show them how much
we would need and try to keep it uniform
but you run into so we got a lot of our
female participants refused to give us
hair samples out of fear of
superstitious beliefs and that's why my
hair sample size was smaller than the
rice and the hair and some so some of
them said said no I'm not going to cut
off any hair for you but I can give you
the leftovers of my from my comb and so
we accepted that but in general we were
trying to just to keep uniformity of how
how much we want from the tips but
unfortunately it wasn't always
successful just because of the
participants willingness to give their
hair samples alright so maybe we should
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu